this episode was made possible by
generous supporters on patreon
hey crazies this is about one kilogram
of mass then again so is this these two
objects are different sizes different
shapes made of different materials and
have different purposes so when I say
something like this is one kilogram what
am I saying about it what the heck is
mass in old school physics mass shows up
in two different places kick it at old
school with my homeboy Newton he's no
fool and that's totally proven he's got
a rule that's meant for computing a
major read cool of a Mass execute
whatever according to Newton's second
law mass measures inertia an object's
ability to resist changes in motion more
mass means less acceleration anyone
who's ever tried to push a broken-down
car knows exactly what I mean the second
place mass appears is in gravity
Newton's universal law of gravity which
is in no way Universal says two masses
exert gravity on each other over some
distance more mass and either object
means more gravity between them both
both laws are aspects of something we
call classical or Newtonian mechanics
for obvious reasons and it works really
well most of the time we know from a lot
of videos on this channel that Newtonian
mechanics doesn't explain everything
it's not fundamentally correct however
to be clear Newton's laws are
unbelievably accurate for 99% of the
things and 99% of the universe most of
the time you're good with Newton but his
laws don't really explain what mass is
just what effects it has which isn't
very satisfying the easiest definition
I've heard is that mass is the amount of
stuff something has inside it but that's
kind of vague
what stuff yeah exactly this is a really
deep question and the deeper questions
we ask the more that 1% of 1% is going
to become important let's focus on that
for a few minutes and maybe we can make
this definition a little more specific
the other 1% of 1% of stuff is governed
by one of two types of physics
relativity and quantum mechanics will
start with relativity because well it's
easier in relativity Newton's second law
of motion and his law of gravity have
been corrected to more closely match the
universe but there's a consequence to
this correction like a lot of things in
relativity mass is relative to the
observer that means it depends on who or
what is measuring it
yes angry commenters relativistic mass
is a real thing
it isn't always useful and sometimes
it's unnecessarily confusing but it's
still a valid way of looking at the
world no matter what a particle
physicists might tell you to understand
this we need to take a look at the most
famous equation of all time e equals MC
squared this mass here is a relativistic
mass whether you're trying to accelerate
an object or you're weighing it on some
kind of scale you're measuring
relativistic mass in other words you're
measuring its complete energy content
that energy could be elastic kinetic
thermal whatever if the object has more
energy it's harder to accelerate it's
affected more by gravity and it
generates more of its own gravity no
matter what type of energy that is but
there's one type of energy that usually
dominates rest energy the part of energy
associated with rest energy is often
called the rest mass so the distribution
usually looks something like this it's
almost all rest mass so we don't have to
distinguish most of the time why do we
call it rest mass it's the mass we'd
measure if it were at rest relative to
us say an object starts to speed up
because it's kinetic energy increases so
does its total mass otherwise known as
relativistic mass but its rest mass
stays the same while rest mass usually
dominates it doesn't always if something
is small enough or moving fast enough
kinetic energy can noticeably contribute
to overall mass there are even things
that don't have any rest mass at all in
order for something to have rest mass it
must have a rest frame there must be a
frame of reference where it is at rest
or stationary light doesn't have one of
those
light is always traveling at the same
speed according to all observers
everywhere
it has relativistic mass but not rest
mass all of its energy is kinetic energy
in fact anything without rest mass is
going to have that same speed weirdness
as light gluons also have no rest mass
so they also travel at the speed of
light for all observers speaking of
gluons let's take a look at quantum
mechanics cuz we still haven't quite
explained everything how is this rest
energy stuff actually energy what is it
it can't just be existence energy
photons and gluons exist and they don't
have it it comes down to what type of
stuff objects are made of you mean steel
no particles steel is mostly iron and
carbon atoms in a crystal solid so far
there's nothing super enlightening steel
has mass because as atoms do ticking a
closer look at one of the atoms we have
the same problem atoms have mass because
they're subatomic particles do and most
of that mass is from the protons and
neutrons inside one of the protons
though something weird happens protons
are made of three quarks but the mass of
those quarks only represents one percent
of the total mass of the proton the
other 99 percent comes from the kinetic
energy of those quarks and more
importantly the binding energy of the
gluon field holding those quarks
together as a proton on a fundamental
level 99% of the mass of you or me what
we would call our rest mass is actually
just other types of energy so the
breakdown actually looks more like this
almost the entire chart is made up of
different types of energy but what about
this remaining 1% that's just the rest
mass of all these particles over here
according to quantum field theory those
particles have mass due to an
interaction with something called the
Higgs field see most quantum fields
hover around zero energy the Higgs field
hovers a little higher than the others
it's equilibrium is a non zero energy
that fills all space the gruesome
details of this will save for another
video in the distant future the point
I'm making here is that it's still about
energy the Higgs field is an energy
field all quantum fields are
what the heck is mass when you measure
the mass of something anything you're
measuring its energy content that energy
can be made up of a wide range of
different types but in the end it's all
about energy and just so I make this
abundantly clear less than 1% of that is
from the Higgs field the other 99% or
more is from other energy that has
nothing to do with Higgs whatever part
of that you happen to be calling mass
just depends on who you are and who
you're talking to but since this famous
equation says that mass is really just
energy maybe it's time we stop
discussing mass altogether so what's the
most massive thing you've ever seen
please share in the comments thanks for
liking this video don't forget to
subscribe if you'd like to keep up with
us and until next time remember it's
okay to be a little crazy the featured
comment comes from Gustavo who asked
what exactly did he mean by detect a
quantum detection observation
measurement whatever you want to call it
is any interaction where one particle
carries away information about the other
in our case the electrons position
anyway crazies thanks for watching